Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radiolab and today, hello?
Yes. Or as a dolphin might say, how would it often say it? I don't know.
Well then that,
you know what that is exactly kind of the question of this next segment.
I mean the dream that a human being and talk to a dolphin or any animal,
really getting their heads cross that gap.
This is a dream that humans have had for since like forever. Yeah.
St Francis of Assisi goes way back now and so far as dolphins are concerned,
after the John Lilly's situation, researchers did get a little tepid,
but they didn't stay tepid as you say, for long.
No, because along came this woman,
Dr Denise Hersey, director of the wild dolphin project,
who basically decided to take John Lily's experiment and flip it rather than
have the dolphin speak English. Let's have the humans speak dolphin,
or at the very least,
let's create a shared language where humans and dolphins can speak
or at least whistle. Well, you know, it's about finding,
finding a place you can meet back to producer Lynn Levy. Okay. So for Denise,
this dream of finding that meeting spot,
it goes back to when she was a little [inaudible].
Well, when I was 12 years old,
I used to page through the encyclopedia Britannica.
In the days when we had books and I would always stop at the whale and Dolphin
page, look at the dolphins and go, wow,
I wonder what their brains are like because they'd evolved in the water that
when you were 12 I was, I was, I was a total nerd. In fact, I,
I entered this contest in Minnesota.
Like what would you do for the world if you could do something?
And I actually wrote,
I would build a human animal translators so we could figure out what was going
on in the minds of animals. So yeah, I don't know.
I got the bug early and here I am.
Do you have, were you having a fantasy about what you might learn or
a fantasy? No, I was just curious. So I don't know. You look in their eyes,
there's definitely something behind there. You just want to know what it is.
Fast forward many years.
Denise got a boat and I went out to The Bahamas. She was like,
if I'm going to study these dolphins, I'm going to do it in the wild.
That's where they live. So she tracked down a pod of wild dolphins. Yep, Yep.
And she just tried to blend in.
I actually anchored the boat in one spot most of the time.
This spot in the Bermuda Triangle in the middle of,
I call it the Dolphin highway, where dolphins come and go.
They could come by if they wanted to and if they didn't, they didn't.
When they would come by,
she and her team would just slip into the water and behave ourselves.
Just sort of watch paying attention to who was who,
which dolphin had a crooked fin, which one didn't, and when they'd leave,
we'd get out. And that's really how we operated for the first five years.
And it had worked five years.
She spent five years just watching not doing anything else. Yes.
Doesn't this take an enormous amount of patients?
Well, sure. I mean, but after about five years they started realizing, well,
these guys aren't going to grab us and pocus and products.
So they started just going about their own business,
like feeding, mating, nursing and talking
[inaudible]
or at least making a lot of noises,
which she and her team would record
[inaudible]
wow. That's all dolphin. Dolphin make things. They make all these, yeah,
like that.
That's like there's like a clicking kind of quaking sound that they make
[inaudible]
sounds like a zipper. Yeah,
they make like whistles that are more kind of distinct and then they make sounds
that are like longer and weirder.
And do you have any sense that each of these sounds means something different?
Well that's exactly what we don't know.
I could tell you what kinds of sounds are correlated with fighting and with
mating or disciplining a calf. What we don't know is,
are there detailed kind of words in there?
Is there a more kind of encoded information?
But what they do know is that each dolphin seems to have its own kind of
signature whistle, which is basically a name.
Every individual has its own name. Peter had a name.
Nobody's ever asked me that. Here's Margaret again. And His name was
s. S. S. S
really? It is almost saying Peter here. Right.
So I can call you Lynn by your whistle and new Robert by your whistle.
Or I could be a dolphin going, hey Lynn. Exactly. Do they do that?
They do. Huh? Not only that, uh,
apparently dolphins will use the names of other dolphins who aren't even around.
Like they can't see them. Like they'll talk about each other behind their backs.
Yes, maybe. Wow.
That means that they're using representations of things which aren't in front of
them, which is sort of like the beginning of language.
If that's what they're doing and we don't know.
But if that's what they're doing, then yeah,
that's kind of like the edge of language. So, you know,
it gives us hope that there's probably more information going on there than we
know.
And now finally she has that device,
which device? The magical, you know,
human animal translator device that she was dreaming of writing about when she
was 12.
She has this box that can generate dolphin noises and it can recognize dolphin
noises. And if it works the way that you know that she's dreaming it all work,
it could be the first like real two way back and forth conversation between a
human and a wild animal.
So we're looking forward to the summer and getting out and getting more data and
really exercising the boxes and see what happens.
[inaudible] we're ready. So I begged my way. A board, everybody good?
So you sick pills left
on July 8th from Florida and headed for The Bahamas to see this pod that she has
been following kind of forever, almost 30 years now.
Boat is called
the RV stoneleigh stoneleigh is the scientific name for this particular type of
Dolphin. The spotted dolphin. Have you seen the spotted dolphin?
I've never seen one in person. What is this boat like?
It's like not a tiny boat,
but it's not a big boat and it was just absolutely full of humans.
And who, who is it? Who are your humans? Well,
there's Denise obviously and you've got a captain. My name's curious man.
First mate. And Yeah, research assistants, Allison Meyers, Les Mason,
Bethany Olier volunteers.
There's a acoustics expert, which is Hoffman.
For a long time I couldn't even figure out where everybody was sleeping cause
the boat seems so small.
It was like there is not room for all these people on this boat.
I knew there's a soft hot soldering iron next to the fridge and I haven't even
gotten to this guy.
His name is dad Starner.
So you didn't have like any dolphin experience before this, right? Oh Hell No.
He's one of the guys who invented Google glass.
I became a computer programmer so I'd never have to leave air conditioning.
Right. And I'm out here. And what is this a hundred degree weather to do what?
So his job on the boat is to, he's in charge of these these boxes.
Those boxes probably costs a hundred K at this point we're looking for funding
for funding. So he's the tech Wiz. When he came down to visit my lab,
I was telling about the two way work and the difficulty with underwater stuff.
And he said, oh,
I build wearable computers because how can you build me an underwater wearable
computer? That shoulder shouldn't be hard four years later,
what does this machine look like? That looks like a toaster,
like one of those fancy chrome toasters,
except you wear it on your chest or they silvery and they are silvery.
They have a bunch of sort of knobs and buttons and speakers on them.
It's got preprogrammed whistles in it.
I can punch a key and it projects whistle eight. Here it was. So B,
yeah, it was just c.
She's programmed in signature whistles of some of the dolphins. Right.
Hellish piece. You
and we uh, made signature whistles for ourselves.
Oh, she can call their names and they can call her names. That's,
that's what you're saying. That is the idea. Yeah. And,
and if they do call her name, this name that she's made for herself,
then the box should be able to recognize it and can tell her that she's been
called by name. It'll actually say into her ear in English, Denise,
this is real time. I call it real time sound recognition, but it's real time,
whistle recognition underwater. How does,
if she's made up this name for herself,
how is it that they're going to know that that's her name? Well,
the idea is that they're learning.
So she gets into the water over and over and she says, you know,
it'd be equivalent of, hi, I'm Denise. Hi,
I'm Denise over and over and over and they learn it. You know,
they developed this little like maybe they'll just start to use it and call her.
So you hope you hope they call you.
I'd be really sad if they didn't call my name, but
Vegas at the very least you could call their names and see how they react.
Right. We'll see. That would be a Eureka moment.
I think if you hit the Lolita button and Lolita suddenly turned and look right
at you with a shock of what the heck? Wow.
That human call me by my signature whistle. Whoa, that, has that happened yet?
It hasn't happened yet
and this is something I just did not appreciate for awhile. I was on this boat.
I was like, why is this so hard? Like this seems like it should be.
These people are so smart, like this should be easy,
but they're just like constantly being defeated by the ocean basically.
Which I'm the ocean is like a worthy foe,
but it's like the first year,
first year was a complete disaster trying to get the hardware to work.
What happened the first year everything broke. It was leaks city.
Basically the boxes just kept shutting down. As soon as they would get in the
that's not good. It's not good. That's sort of not what you want. No.
And last year the boxes working, but then we couldn't find the dolphins.
The dolphins just disappeared. They go,
uh, you know, they went a hundred miles away to another location.
They don't know why.
I kept up with my side of the deal. Today's your dolphins stood you up.
Jeez.
And one of the reasons I was on the boat is it felt like everybody was thinking
like, this is it. This is the year we're going to go out there.
We're going to find some dolphins and we're going to make some history.
You ready
now?
Any minute now?
Okay. It turns out it's not that easy to find these dolphins.
They're not tagged.
You know they're wild dolphins so you just like you go to where you think they
might be.
You know that song you stare at the water and you wait
for the first three days? Pretty much I would. We were just driving around
in circles like literally in circles, you know?
I feel like I had like a like a five hour conversation about game of Thrones.
I've never even seen an episode of game of Thrones. Any dolphins anywhere.
No.
It was nothing else to do. All just come on dolphins. We need you now.
Come on off and on. Dog. Come on dog to kick in.
Oh see piece of seaweed. It looked like a dolphin.
Dolphins wave that looks like a dolphin. I just say that I would be like,
everything looks like a dolphin to me right now. There are days like that
open.
They are right there. All of a sudden out on the water we see one fin,
two fins, three fences, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Oh, there's so many of them and they're so cool
standing there watching them. Denise turns to me and she goes,
do you want to go in? I don't know, do you recommend it?
And I was not prepared for her to say that. And also it's holding,
recording equipment, everything. And so I just,
I ended up just having to go in like in my clothes,
like wearing like my shorts and like a bra and I had like all modesty aside,
like thrown aside and they were like, you can go in. And I was like, Oh okay.
Okay, okay. Okay.
Jesus Christ. Here we go.
I mean it's a total sensory shift.
The temperature changes, everything goes quiet.
No,
it almost feels like this, like the classic through the looking glass moment.
Where are you?
Like you go through the looking glass and like everybody's walking on the
ceiling.
[inaudible] and I jumped in and there were two pretty big dolphins coming right
at me. Like maybe two feet from my head,
um, and staring at me and I was like, uh,
I don't know. What do you know? What did you do? I stayed very,
still pretty much froze now. How far were they from me? Two feet.
Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah. Dolphins are not small.
And they were looking at me in a way that was like,
we see you and also there they make these um,
sort of clicking sonar sounds, which are like,
they were talking to you or are just talking about. We'll know what I mean.
What I think they were doing is, is,
is sonar in me sort of looking at me with their, with sound. I mean,
my head was vibrating. I mean they can see not just body shape.
They can see your bones. Oh,
they can see into you. Like you really feel looked at.
Wow. It was heart stopping.
[inaudible]
Oh, is unfit? Believable?
Oh, that's so cool.
I thought when it's like the trip couldn't know and I go home happy, you know,
and everybody was like, calm down.
Those weren't even the right dolphins. What do you mean? Well,
those were bottlenose dolphins. Denise studies spotted [inaudible]. Uh, but
the next day, all right, onward for spots, spots or bust,
we set out again, go for a few hours.
Bethany does this.
Dolphin daily's energetic spot it and okay.
God saw. Yeah. Floor. You saw them, right? Yeah.
Right there. Yeah. There we go. Gotta be spotted.
So then everybody's like, you know, it's like all hands on deck situation.
Everybody's like strapping on the boxes and strapping on the headphones,
which is a lot of scrambling. There's so much scrambling. Oh,
there's one off the bow here. It's like a fire. It's like a fire drill.
Now I'm putting on my box. Here's the problem.
I'm just testing. I'm like a captive dolphin. Wild Dolphins.
They have other things to do. They have, you know, fish to catch.
You kind of have to entice it into having a conversation.
Otherwise it'll just swim away.
But how do you do that when you don't know its language? Well,
turns out dolphins are just crazy for scarves, skirt,
scarf flow. When you throw them a scarf,
they sweep it up with their tailfin and then they let it go and it wafts through
the water and another dolphin comes up and sweeps it up with their rostrum.
So the idea is you use the scarf as kind of like a a bridge.
Denise and another diver will get in the water with a scarf.
We'll get in the water and we'll just start passing it back and forth.
It's human to human like, Hey, look at this funding we're doing. Let them watch.
If they want to get in the game, we let them in the game.
Sometimes we'll take the toy over to them,
show it to them and press the word for scarf. Say, hey, this is a scarf.
They just made up a whistle for scarf. Yup. And ideally, and this is the key,
the dolphins will pick up the word and use it to,
to ask for the scarf if and when they do that,
then you've got like a tiny bit of common ground that you can build on.
Okay, well you got, yeah, four spotted dolphins. Yeah. Little candidates.
Alex. Yes. We've been waiting for them, right? Yeah. Just before they jump in.
Denise walks another diver through the game plan. Oh,
so you're going to hold it and you're not going to give it to him. Okay.
You're going to entice it with them. You're going be like, oh, this is fun.
I like dive down with it and like wave it or, yeah,
start at the surface and just really get them with you moments later.
All clear. Good. We're ready
and he's jumps in followed by three other divers.
Where are you in the water at this time? No,
I actually had to watch the whole thing from the deck and like you could see
from the surface,
three or four adolescents often see the nieces right up next to one of them.
You see the back of her head and her little snorkel. That's good.
She's surrounded right now. What are they doing? I'm not sure. Oh,
they're kind of like twisting around each other. I will say this.
She is tremendously graceful in the water.
She gets in the water and she's like totally at home so maybe she is a tough
that she might secretly be a dolphin going like around and around as she goes on
there. And what is happening under there?
This is what it sounds like underwater.
This is the actual sound from the scarf
dance. They record everything that goes on under there.
Yeah.
I mean a lot of that is the dolphins just doing whatever they're doing.
But some of it is nice with the box making this scarf whistle over and over like
scarf. You want the scar? Yeah. Scarf.
Cause she's like trying to get the dolphin to say the word right. Yeah.
Eventually she and the dolphins surface and
he's got the scarf. One of the dolphins is holding the scar. Hey,
it's like this flash of red and then they all go back under
[inaudible].
If Denise comes back up with it, that's real good. All right, wait and see.
[inaudible]
after about a minute, she surfaces. I think the niece has it now.
She dies one more time.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
a minute later, Dolphin has the scarf and this went on and on.
They were passing it back and forth so fluidly that I thought maybe the Dolphin
has begun to ask for the scarf by name.
Eventually lease gets gravity, sucks all the back up onto the boat
and we all just sort of gather around like, well, well yeah,
the two juveniles picked up the scarf right away and played some signature
whistles, played some scarf whistles.
And then some sargassum paid flooding buys piece of seaweed showed up.
Matt played the Sargassum. Listen, you think you got an email?
Nothing that triggered the system, but you know, let's see what it looks like.
It's exhausting page. She didn't get anything. Well, I mean, nothing the box,
it's recognized as a match, you know,
nothing that indicated the dolphin like learned a word.
Ah,
sounded like they were right there.
But there was this one thing that happened. She said that when she,
um, addressed one of the dolphins by its name, uh,
the dolphin turned around and looked at her and kind of cocked it's little
dolphin head. Really? Yes.
[inaudible].
So, so for the insane, wow.
Also there was this moment where that,
and Celeste were looking at the data later. Who's that?
And they saw that right after Denise made her signature whistle cause that
somebody's responding with her seizure was another dolphin made its signature
whistle. Sweet. Oh that's pretty, you mean like she
said hi in it said hi back. Yeah. That's amazing. Well maybe, I mean
the thing is dolphins make their signature whistles all the time.
So it could be nothing or it could be this.
I mean, she's a very rigorous scientist.
Like she wants that to happen another 30 times before even starting to take it
seriously.
But still it does make you think about the possibilities.
What do you want to ask?
I don't know. I want to ask everything.
So like what,
I'd like to know what their lives are like when we're not around.
And then how do you spend your day, you know, do they think about things?
I mean, do they think about the future? Did they think about the past? I mean,
we know they have longterm memories, you know,
do they remember their calves from 10 years ago? Do they think about death?
Yeah. And they certainly see it could be anything you'd ask your friends. Right?
[inaudible]
although part of me wonders like,
I think we're going to get even get there. What do you mean?
Well that's the goal is to have a conversation and he can't do it this way where
you're in the wild and you can't touch them and you've got to verify every
whistle 35 times.
What are they ever actually going to have a conversational because was like they
one of the language lesson I can I, yeah, I get it.
But like don't you feel like Margaret was a,
all the problems with that experiment aside which she was actually getting
somewhere with Peter.
Like they were actually having a real exchange in the moment perhaps.
But thinking forward,
I believe that what you can accomplish by talking,
by having a two way conversation,
infinitely greater. Yeah. And I totally agree.
But if it's taken her 30 something years to get to a maybe hello?
Yeah.
She doesn't even know if she got to hello yet and if all she has is a just a
limited amount of time with these dolphins every summer,
then 50 more times as you can tell you're 50 more years and I'm just like,
Oh God, the plant is going to be 17 degrees warmer. By that point,
dolphins are going to have all migrated to some other spot. It just feels like,
oh, come on. Just get in a pool and hold. Let, let,
let the Dolphin hold your foot. She's already got the hello going for her.
Maybe so that's like a start and then yes,
in 50 years she may have moved past hello to a three word sentence.
How's your macro today? Yeah. I think that to a three word sentence. Yes.
I would put money on a three word sentence in 50 years. The question is,
do we ever get to the point of exploring death? Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know. Lynn, do you have faith [inaudible]
I have faith that if Denise continues with what she's doing that we'll be able
to talk about concrete
things. We'll be able to talk about seaweed and we'll be able to talk about,
um, coral and we'll be able to have a scintillating conversation about scarves.
I do believe that, and that is not nothing. I mean,
that is pretty impressive in its own way.
Big thanks to [inaudible] to our producer.
I'm Jack. I'm Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thank you guys for listening.